if you know me no doubt by now you are
aware that i
have a soft spot in my heart
for magical realism
for magical realism as a way of being
that goes beyond mere naive realism
naive realism is the transactional realm
it's the quotidian and the everyday it
is the banality
and arrogance of the benders and scene
bats of the adult mind and i
have freed
myself
friends
i have
freed myself
from
god
oh i have freed myself from this naive
realism because instead friends i have
figured out the protocols and procedures
for booting up a new semiotic universe
for booting up a kind of magical realism
a theater of the absurd a kind of
aesthetic realm that i can dwell in a
waking dream where i create and perceive
my world i am speaking to you about
deploying a poetic consciousness about
spraying the world with effervescence
about awakening the lethargy of custom
and the film of familiarity and
redirecting it instead towards the
wonders of existence i have figured out
friends how to literally live in a realm
of magical realism i am not exaggerating
when i say to you that i know how to
italicize perception i know how to set
the world to music i know how to
re-enchant
continuously my field of awareness i
literally live in a poem of my own
choosing and this kind of magical
realism is akin to turning your life
into a work of art to thinking of your
life like a living film
we are living
cinema time becomes liquid upon this
realization that you can enchant and
paint the world with mind that you can
author stories that you can live in a
story world of your own making magical
realism can be more real than mere naive
realism in all of its banality it is
like when alan de boton talks about the
difference between a poet and a
journalist you know the quotidian and
the miraculous he says a journalist may
be more accurate describing the details
of an event than a poet but a poet may
nevertheless reveal truth of a deeper
sort beyond the literal grid so when i
speak about magical realism i speak
about realms beyond the literal grid
magical realism is beyond the literal
grid it is beyond the naivete of cynics
the naivete of of of the brooding
resignation of fatalists and nihilists
they've missed the plot they've lost the
through line this naive realism that
over materializes that over simplifies
that robs the world of all of its poetry
is such poverty and such ignorance
friends because they are not awake they
are asleep but those of us that realize
that the world is made out of pure
imagination can drape the cosmos with
story and song and we can sing the songs
that orchestrate the universe and space
and time and mind can collapse into each
other as time becomes liquid and we
become cinema we've stopped trying to
make art and we have become art like
samurais or the karate kid we get into
position and we cue the song and it all
just happens it all just happens and we
have moved from an ordinary world
because the world is full of magic
things patiently waiting for our senses
to grow sharper this is what yates wrote
or the poet nizakartata the other world
the dream world we long for is this
world rightly seen
magical realism is simply this world
rightly seen it can be like the film
amelie we can literally make our lives
song we can become poetry so if you're
feeling cynical in the throngs of
despair living a life of quiet
desperation drudgering away in
unconsciousness in the default setting
in the rat race in that constant gnawing
sense of having had and lost some
infinite thing as david foster wallace
wrote know this friends the promised
land the the pot of gold at the end of
the rainbow it's all there for the
taking if you open your eyes and
understand the protocols and procedures
for booting up magical realism right
song is proof that the human race is
greater than it knows right cinema is
truth 24 times per second move beyond
naive realism and go into the realm of
ecstatic truth of literature of poetry
and
song
and friends
like the greatest moments of your life
that no doubt you've known so well that
first kiss that moment when somebody
moved you to the point of tears when
something somewhere incredible waiting
to be known was finally seen and you
were like ah
more of this you will know what's
possible and you know what i'm talking
about and so that friends is what i want
to leave you with like don't
don't brood
don't
don't
don't dismiss don't grow old don't grow
cynic don't lose the faith don't lose
the plot
friends don't lose the blood for the
world is full of magic things patiently
waiting for our senses to grow sharper
and there's a
literally a field of possibility a
possibility space at the doorstep of
every moment ready to be seized in a
kind of ecstatic absolution and deep
play and improvisational theater and
dance and song
and art and truth
the truth that sets us free the truth
from which nothing can dislodge us
catalepsis the greeks call it
this is what is possible this
is magical realism and this
is what we're here to do
it's what we're here to do
it's what we're here
to do